it's beau rusia Dortmund's last practice
before flying to London coach Jurgen
Klopp has to figure out how to replace
Mario Gotze that many locals say the
team will do just fine Jagran suicide
what is good said done lately he's
missed so many shots if he'd slipped up
against Bayern Munich people would have
said he did it to let them win you mean
I no futher finish out of him it's too
bad he can't play but that's the way it
is now we have to see who they come up
with it's what comes in doesn't I'll do
not you if you need with or without guts
ax people in Dortmund are getting ready
for a big night of soccer beer trucks
are already prowling downtown people
will either drink away their sorrows or
celebrate a championship win there's
even a special pastry in honor of the
game the guy said I'm just so excited
and so are our customers these are
selling like hotcakes with two days
before the final there's still time for
locals to plaster the names of their
favorite stars all over town